before we go we gotta leave you some
good vibes which actually also might be
leaving you with some tears jason momoa
chopped off his luscious locks over the
weekend but it's all for a good cause
yes the aquaman star toasted to new
beginnings and his love for the
environment chopping off his signature
hair to highlight the issue of
single-use plastics and he caught the
whole transformation on camera enjoy
everyone we'll see you next time bye
hello everyone
um hand me those
braids
so
i'm shaving off the hair
doing it for uh
oh
oh man
i've never even felt the wind right
there
do it for uh
single-use plastics
i'm tired of these plastic bottles we
gotta stop
plastic forks all that
just goes into our land goes into our
ocean
i'm here in hawaii right now
i'm just seeing
things in our ocean it's just so sad so
please
anything you can do
to eliminate single-use plastics in your
lives
help me
help me plastic bottles are ridiculous
bringing your canteen or
now everyone's making the aluminum which
is fantastic so
aloha
we're going to keep going oh man
kenny girl
all right i love you guys